Zunächst einmal möchte ich den Gastgebern
für die Einladung und
das Aufkommen des Themas danken. Dies ist ein Thema, von dem ich
sehr gehofft hatte, dass es viel
mehr wissenschaftliche Aufmerksamkeit erhalten würde, also war ich sehr
aufgeregt und deshalb habe ich mich dafür entschieden  Kommen Sie
noch einmal, vielen Dank für die
Einladung und die Idee. Es ist sehr
spannend,
heute werde ich hauptsächlich als
Wissenschaftshistoriker und über die
Anwendung des Konzepts Sweep In in
den Naturwissenschaften in den aufkommenden
Themen der
Biowissenschaften sprechen, sagte Marnya  dies ist ganz im
Sinne meines jüngsten Buches. Der Begriff Sweep
spielte eine zentrale Rolle in den sich entwickelnden
Biowissenschaften des späten 18. Jahrhunderts
in Deutschland. Der Kontrast zwischen teeb und
husteten Neos und Bestien hob das
Ausgestorbene hervor, das unverwechselbare Gebiet des Lebens
als Kontrast dazu  allgemeinere physikalisch-
chemische Kräfte in Naturgewalt oder
Bestien hatten sich als das wichtigste
Konzept für die Komplikation der
mechanischen Philosophie von ihren Prämissen aus dem 17.
Jahrhundert erwiesen, um sie zu umfassen  eine ganze
Reihe von ätherischen Flüssigkeiten und feinstofflichen
Dingen wie Schwerkraft, Wärme, Licht, Magnetismus,
Elektrizität und chemische Affinität
, die zur Hauptbeschäftigung dessen wurden, was ich als
experimentelle Newtonsche ISM bezeichne, im Gefolge
von Newtons Fragen zur Optik von
1706, die diese Kräfte für reale
Elemente der Natur hielten  dramatisch
veränderte physikalische Theorie vom
Modell der trägen Masse, dh Bewegung nur durch
äußere Einwirkung oder Mechanismen, zur
Vorstellung einer Hierarchie von anziehenden
und abstoßenden Kräften, die unmittelbar
die natürliche Welt bewegen, die wir als
vitalen Materialismus bezeichnen könnten, wie ich und eine Reihe meiner
Kollegen es tun  Anfangs beinhaltete der
Begriff der Kraft oder v's die
aufstrebenden Biowissenschaften, so angesprochen'd
Valhalla bezeichnete seine zu experimentell
diskriminierten Formen der Tierphysiologie
Reizbarkeit und Sensibilität als
Ladenskriptor, und diese Verwendung des
Handwerks oder seines lateinischen Verwandten
charakterisierte auch die
bahnbrechende Theorie von Cosmo Friedreichs Wolf  der Generation im
Visa-Sinne Yanis  und in der Tat durchdrang der Begriff
beladen verspottet den
Diskurs über das Leben in Deutschland im späten 18. Jahrhundert, und
ich denke, nur in diesem Zusammenhang
können wir die entscheidende
terminologische Bedeutung von Johann
Friedrich Blumenbach beim Übergang von
diesem Begriff der gehusteten Bestien oder Gewalt
zum Begriff von erkennen  von 1740 bis zu seinem Tod im Jahr 1777 dominierte der Antrieb Nizzas, aber
auch und hier sein bahnbrechender
Instinkt die deutsche Lebenswissenschaft
eine lange und erfolgreiche karriere verband
ihn als lehrerkollege als mentor mit
nahezu allen bedeutenden gestaltern
der branche, so dass blumenbach bis weit
ins 19. jahrhundert hinein zum patriarchen der deutschen lebenswissenschaften
avancierte. der frage nach der entstehung
und dem stich organisierter körperschaften stand blumenbach
entgegen  Alle Bemühungen der modernen
Wissenschaft zitieren eines der schwierigsten
Themen von  physiologie unquote er
erarbeitete zitate wo aus dem ursprünglichen
grundstoff ein von jeder tierischen pflanze gefressener hirsch komma haarausfall
entsteht
und durch welche kräfte
CAFTA dieser stoff später
entwickelt wird mouseka baut er oder jedes problem
dessen lösung
bisher im dunkeln lag
Unquote Ich habe all diese deutschen Wörter
hier verwendet, obwohl ich immer
alles ins Englische übersetzen werde,
weil es äußerst wichtig ist, was
die Schlüsselbegriffe sind, durch die dieser
Begriff philosophisch
bedeutsam wird
Schlaf
hat dieses Phänomen absichtlich
von den anderen Ballons Clifton getrennt,
die in der physischen und sogar
der organischen Welt identifiziert wurden. Dieser Scrim
erwies sich als wichtig für [ __ ] und später
noch für gute 10 Schilling, und das ist
Beschuss, und darum geht es auf dieser Konferenz,
also in meinem  bestimmten Aufsatz,
was ich tun möchte, ist zu versuchen
rekonstruieren Sie die Quelle und die
Bedeutung von blumenbach stern bis t
p-- und mein Argument wird sein, dass
Blueback auf der
Pionierarbeit von Hema und Romero aus Europa stammt, und
deshalb wird mein Aufsatz eine Versuchsteilstruktur
haben. Zuerst werde ich darüber sprechen, was sich
reimt  eros hat mit baum gemacht, darüber haben wir
schon viel gehört und
ich werde versuchen, meine Ausführungen dazu entsprechend zu komprimieren
, dann stelle ich fest,
was blumenbach persönlich mit den
Zähnen gemacht hat, als er das Konzept
des Schlafaufbaus entwickelt hat, und ich werde kurz schließen  mit
der Art und Weise, wie [ __ ] diese
Denkweise von Lumba im Gegensatz zu meinem
Vorredner erhielt, werde ich
hauptsächlich über den letzten Text von
Romero sprechen, sagt die großartige Trilogie der 1750er Jahre,
sein Streit um coq10 und Ruby, liebe Dare
, tiga, Hilfe, sicher, Ruby, gekniffen, Kiba
aus dem Jahr 1760, und was ich andeuten möchte, ist,
dass er diese Arbeit speziell unternommen hat, um das
zu widerlegen, was ein medizinischer
Geass von 1755 angerichtet hat, der versucht hat
, ihn tierisches Verhalten zu erklären o  n dem
Muster des menschlichen Lernens, das wir aus
Sinneserfahrungen gewonnen haben, und eines der Dinge
, die wir in all diesen
Diskussionen über unsere Maus zu sehen beginnen, ist, wie
außerordentlich genau und schnell er
auf französischsprachige Texte reagiert, wenn wir
an das Werk von 1754 denken und  Es ist
verantwortlich, so tiba argumentieren, Minor, aber
Nachmittag ist eine sehr schnelle Antwort auf
Kentucky und nebenbei auch, um
das zu tun, was Prime Arrows tun will, ist es
grundlegend, die zentrale
These zu bestreiten, dass Tiere durch die Erfahrung gelernt haben
, die analog zur menschlichen
Entwicklung war, und gegen diese
Hauptpfeile wollten auf den angeborenen
Charakter des tierischen Instinkts oder Triebs bestehen, der
bereits in der Form namens Ofen
erhöht wurde, von 1754 bot er eine klare
Zustimmung zur
Verwirklichung der wesentlichen Merkmale
des Konzepts an, das darin bestand
, ein selbstnutzendes Ziel zu verfolgen,
ohne es zu zitieren  jede individuelle
Reflexionserfahrung und Praxis ohne
Trainingsbeispiel oder Methode von Geburt
an mit  eine
von Geburt an bereite kunstlose Kunstfertigkeit, die meisterhaft darin war
, ihr Ziel zu erreichen, unzitiert, und er
versprach, dass er diese
Theorie des Schlafs in einem späteren Werk näher erläutern würde
, und das hat sich T Bhatia von 1760 vorgenommen
, um das zu tun, was er tut und was wir darin
gesehen haben  Die beiden vorherigen Präsentationen
sollen diese Untersuchung in die allgemeine
Frage der Tier-Mensch-Grenze und
die spezifische Frage der Natur der
Tierseele einordnen, die beide
außerordentlich zentrale Themen für den gesamten
Diskurs des 18. Jahrhunderts waren, und hier ist, was
Romero glaubte, dazu in der Lage zu sein
in seinem riesigen buch von 1760 zitiere
ich aus den kräften der tiere
und aus den eigenschaften der geschickten
triebe kunst liebe nachweisen, dass sie nicht
in einer wirksamkeit bestehen, die
die tiere durch
erfahrung und vernunft noch durch irgendeinen
vernunftgrad für sich erlangten, sondern  dass dies
vererbte Fähigkeiten sind, die aus
den bestimmten natürlichen Kräften von
Tieren und Gabanna-Fetisch hervorgehen, erhöht int
Nun, er entschied, dass
Attila und Dampf nicht auf der Grundlage umfangreicher
Dokumentationen und tierischer und sinnlicher
Verhaltensweisen von Morrow hergestellt wurden, um zwischen
allgemeiner Selbsterhaltung und einer
spezielleren Manifestation zu unterscheiden, die er
die Kunst billiger oder geschickter Triebe nannte, und
dies war tatsächlich sein Hauptanliegen
Tatsächlich ist der konzipierte Begriff wahrscheinlich das theoretisch fruchtbarste Konzept, das Lumba oder Romero
zu dem sich entwickelnden Feld beigetragen haben, aber was
ich tun möchte, ist, auf die technischen Einzelheiten einzugehen,
wie er diesen Begriff des Schlafes auslegte,
und er schreibt tief im Allgemeinen, dass er
alles umfasst  natürliches Streben
nach bestimmten Handlungen unser weniger
natürlicher
Sinn, dies in Jagdleinen unquote zu geben
und er zeichnete sich durch Const aus alle
geschickte Tätigkeit alle Zitat reglementierten
regelgebundenen Fähigkeiten zu bestimmten
Handlungen und somit waren die entscheidenden
Merkmale des Nachschlafes, dass er sowohl
natürlich als auch war  noch
ein sanftes, dh es beinhaltete ein gewisses Maß an
Zweck, kurz was  romeros
in seiner konzeption des tierischen
verhaltens gelangte sozusagen die idee der
unmittelbaren zielstrebigkeit wieder zu einem schlüsselbegriff
, der Kant interessieren wird
und der gerade in dem
genannten zitat um die erhaltung und das
wohl des tieres treibend war  und seine Art
nach einer feindlichen Handlung des Destillateurs
besitzt es, der Zionist Geshe, der linke Unzitat,
es war jedoch ganz und gar angeboren, dies
war seine überragende theoretische
Beharrlichkeit gegen Leute wie seine
französischen Rivalen, die alle Tabor waren, wie er es ausdrückte
, und Dowd wurde vom Schöpfer des Namensschiffs mit
Pelz gestochen  Unzitiert am
Ende seines Kapitels über das ständige Fieber
Romeros bekanntes Zitat Mit dem Begriff
geschickte Triebe bezeichne ich die Sache
selbst, die vor den Augen
aller zu beobachten ist, aber nicht die Ursache oder
die Art und Weise ihrer Möglichkeit, die man
erst kennenlernen muss  mit der
Materie selbst nach ihren tatsächlichen
Eigenschaften, bevor man fragen kann, wie alles
, was wirklich an Tieren
beobachtet wurde, p  möglich
unquote während die Wechselwirkung zwischen
Seele und Körper letztendlich ein
Rätsel war und wie es tatsächlich funktioniert, wird
es für uns immer unmöglich sein zu wissen
unquote dennoch haben Erfahrung und
Beobachtung deutlich gemacht, dass solche
Wechselwirkungen sowohl bei Tieren
als auch bei Menschen stattgefunden haben, halte ich für außerordentlich
wichtig Ich schlage vor, dass genau das,
was Rui Morris hier tut, die
Unterscheidung zwischen der Praxis der
empirischen wissenschaftlichen Erforschung von Leben
und Verhalten
und philosophischer Spekulation macht, und er
behauptet, dass Naturwissenschaftler tatsächlich
keine Metamediziner sein müssen.
Ich denke, das ist sehr wichtig
für die  Zukunft der Lebenswissenschaften sowohl in
Deutschland als auch im Westen zusammenfassend
ihn noch einmal zitieren, müssen wir es
wagen, den tatsächlichen Zusammenhang
zwischen Seele und Körper lediglich
erfahrungsgemäß anzunehmen, auch wenn wir uns
die Natur dieser neutralen Wechselwirkung nicht
erklären können und dies eine war  grundlegende
methodologische Maxime für empirische
Forschung  Nachdem Ezra Morris glaubte, dass
die erneute Codierung für die ursprünglichen essentiellen
Kräfte in Übereinstimmung mit ihrer
regulären Bestimmung die erste Runde
aller Tatsachen der Natur ist, und alle
Philosophen müssen anerkennen, dass es
unmöglich ist, a priori
weitere philosophische oder mathematische
Beweise für die fundamentalen Kräfte zu bestimmen
der dinge und ihrer gesetzmäßigkeiten, aber
sie müssen sie einfach
gemäß der erfahrung annehmen,
um weiter zu forschen, unzitiert, das
möchte ich andeuten, dass
romeros methodologie in dieser arbeit über
teba diese methodologische
empirische antwort und die verunglimpfung betont hat
keine erkenntnistheoretische
oder insbesondere ontologische Lösung
dieser letzten Fragen zu erreichen, und was ich
vorschlagen möchte, ist, dass uns dies sowohl einen
inhaltlichen als auch einen methodologischen Schlüssel dafür gibt,
was Blumenbach
in seiner eigenen Arbeit aus dem Begriff des Schlafes machen will
in seinem einflussreichen Handbuch stellte
sich als verschoben heraus  mit zahlreichen Ergänzungen
ab 1779 befasste sich Blumenbach mit
all diesen entscheidenden Fragen der
Tier-Mensch-Grenze und der Natur
des Tierverhaltens, und was ich andeuten möchte,
ist, dass er sich von
Anfang an auf die Arbeit von Romano stützte,
obwohl er dies nur ausdrücklich
anerkannte  Quelle vieler seiner Ideen in späteren
Ausgaben des Jagdbuchs Alle
Argumente, die er verwendete und die er
in späteren Ausgaben mit Fußnoten versehen hat,
waren
in der Originalausgabe genau in derselben Sprache
und sie stammen alle von Romanos, was
Bloom Bock aus seinem
Verständnis ableitete  nicht nur von Romero, sondern
allgemeiner war, dass der Mensch sich so
radikal von allem anderen
im Tierreich unterschied, dass selbst
Linné bei dem Versuch, seine
Kategorie von Primaten
zu schaffen, auf Abwege geraten war
diese Kategorie
, die ihn innerhalb der
Tierwelt auszeichnete
, nannte er Menschen in Armeen, das
heißt Defensive  ss und was er
damit genau meinte, war, dass er im Gegensatz zu allen
anderen Tieren weder
mit Verhaltensweisen noch mit körperlichen
Merkmalen ausgestattet war, die sie vor ihrer
Umwelt schützten und sie in ihrer
ökologischen Nische sicherten, sondern vielmehr
dem Lernen durch Vernunft überlassen war und
es Vernunft war  das machte all diese
Schwächen wett, von denen die Menschen geplagt wurden,
und was Blue Mark argumentierte, war, dass
genau diese Schwäche es den Menschen
ermöglichte, in viele verschiedene Umgebungen einzudringen
und sich im gesamten
Reich der Natur zu etablieren, all dies sind Ideen
, die sehr aufgegriffen und entwickelt werden
Sehr reich von Hera und anderen Schriften
später, aber sie sind bereits in Blumenbach
in diesen Argumenten, aber ich möchte nur
sehen, wo diese allgemeine Sorge um die
Natur der Beziehung zwischen Mensch
und Tier zum Fesselschlaf führt,
und hier muss ich einführen  eine eher
biografische und sozialwissenschaftliche
Konzeption nämlich Bloom Box Angst
davor, uns den Rücken zu stoßen, wenn Hanna  Als
Blumenbach Halle verehrte, konnte er
ihn nie persönlich treffen, weil
Haller bereits in die Schweiz
zurückgekehrt war, als Mumbai ankam,
aber sofort wurde er in
Korrespondenz mit Halle gebracht, die er
als das große Vorbild eines Wissenschaftlers vergötterte,
und er akzeptierte  Heuler-Theorie der
Präformation als zweifelsohne die richtige
Theorie für viele Jahre,
und dann begann er, es sich anders zu
überlegen, und er begann, selbst viel
empirische Forschung über
Süßwasserpolypen durchzuführen, die kurz vor dem Eindringen standen, und
er hatte begonnen, eine Reihe von zu entwickeln
Vorbehalte gegen Haller, aber er sagte
kein Wort, bis der große alte Mann starb
und so die wichtigste Trennung meiner
Meinung nach zwischen der Blütezeit der sehr
sehr berühmten Dissertation von 1775 und dem
Beginn der Handbuchdrehung von AutoKey
verschoben wurde, ist der Tod von Albert Wann
Halle Ende 1777, die
Blumenbach endlich befreite
, seine eigenen Ideen angstfrei buchstabieren zu können und
deshalb schon 1780 in einer neuen
Zeitschrift für die  Naturwissenschaften
, die von seinen Freunden Lichtenberg
und 4-Sterne-Blumenbach entwickelt wurden, veröffentlichten einen
bahnbrechenden Aufsatz. Das erste Unternehmen
, in dem er seine eigene Theorie artikulierte,
hieß Human Window Sleep News for
Mateus und auf Zenon I'm through self
Deegan Art gezeigt auf Leopard gezeigt so in
mit diesem titel bekommen wir bereits die
ankündigung einer radikal neuen
annäherung an die probleme die zentralen
probleme der lebenswissenschaften blumenbach hatte
zuvor
fünf jahre experimentell an diesen ideen gearbeitet und
erst jetzt in diesem zusammenhang fühlt er
sich frei, diese zu erforschen  Ideen, was
ich vorschlagen möchte, ist, dass er von
Anfang an eine bestimmte Definition
des Bauplans hat, die er nie wirklich
ändert, so dass diese Vorstellung für Blumenbach vollständig ausgeformt ist,
wenn er
diesen kleinen Aufsatz im Jahr 1780 veröffentlicht, er
wird optimiert und ich  Werde die methodologische Argumentation
II in Folgearbeiten ergänzen,
aber die
Grundkonzeption ändert sich praktisch nicht um ein
Wort im Laufe des Kurses  se von vielen, vielen
Wiedergaben davon, und er kam zu dem, was er
sagte, nicht nur auf der Grundlage, dass
er nach Tremblay an seinen geliebten Polypen gearbeitet hatte,
sondern auch auf der
Grundlage eines chirurgischen Experiments oder einer
Erfahrung, mit der er sich
befasste  Bei einer sehr schweren
Knieverletzung hinterließ der Heilungsprozess eine
erhebliche Depression in der physischen
Form, dass die Masse reduziert wurde und dass er
irgendwie zu sehen begann, dass
die
Wirksamkeit des Lebewesens zur Regeneration nachließ, obwohl
es eindeutig eine Anstrengung gab  zu und eine
Macht dazu war nie ganz
die gleiche Stärke wie in seiner
ursprünglichen Formulierung, und er sagte, aus
diesen beiden bin ich zu einer allgemeinen
theoretischen Schlussfolgerung gekommen und versuche das
Erstaunliche und Weitreichende, dass diese Theorie über
das ausgesprochen werden kann, was scheint  für mich
ziemlich schwache Beweissäulen, aber
nichtsdestotrotz dachte er
, dass er das in allen Lebewesen getan hatte,
vom Menschen bis zur Milbe und von der Zeder bis zum
Schimmel. Bitte wissen Sie, dass Ro  mero suchte
pflanzen waren keine lebewesen eine ziemlich
dumme position, obwohl es aus
seiner metaphysik folgt, nicht, da die biologie
blumenbach nie unter einer solchen
illusion gearbeitet hat, also hier ist es vom menschen zur milbe
und von der zeder zum formen ein
unverwechselbarer angeborener dr3 angeborener antrieb ok
das ist Romeros Sprache  ok, also es ist
definitiv ein Mürrischer, aber
er geht schon von meinem Morgen
als Lebenswissenschaftler ab Lügen, die am Anfang
über ihre gesamte Lebensdauer aktiv am Werk bleiben
, um ihnen zu helfen
, ihre endgültige Form anzunehmen, um sie dann zu
erhalten und wenn diese zerstört wird als
so gut wie möglich, um es wiederherzustellen, und
hier ist das Maß der Verringerung, der
Rückgang der Regeneration, er geht auf eine
Fahrt oder Neigung oder Bemühung, wie auch immer
man es nennen möchte, bitte
beachten Sie, dass wir
gerade in der Pause darüber gesprochen haben, es ist nicht der
Begriff, der läuft  dass blumenbach darüber streiten will, dass es um die
tatsache geht, dass sich diese
phänomene in der biologie entwickeln a  Ein Trieb
, der sich sowohl von den
allgemeinen Eigenschaften aller
Körper als auch von den anderen
charakteristischen Kräften, die von
organisierten Körpern im Besonderen hergestellt werden, völlig unterscheidet und der
als eine der ursprünglichen
Ursachen aller Fortpflanzung erscheint, kann
Ernährung und Regeneration Regeneration
Reproduktion nicht sehen und in dem ich mich befinde  Um
alle Fehlinterpretationen zu vermeiden und
um es von anderen Naturgewalten zu unterscheiden,
baut der Name formative Drive auf dem Steilnachrichtenformat von
Evo auf. Blue Box möchte
hier also suggerieren, dass er
etwas deutlich anderes gefunden hat,
das mit einem anderen
Begriff bezeichnet werden muss  Von allen zuvor verwendeten Begriffen,
während es denen ähnlich ist, ist es
unverwechselbar, und diese Unterscheidungskraft, die er
im Kontrast zwischen
nett und Vees einfangen möchte, ist das wirklich
wissenschaftlich und theoretisch Entscheidende
an dieser Innovation, und sie ist
von Anfang an da, wovon Lombok nie
abweicht  dass es der Kern seiner
Vorstellung von was ist  Er hat in seiner
Arbeit etwas erreicht, und er besteht darauf, dass niemand sonst
und keine andere Theorie der Lebenskräfte
wirklich verwendet werden kann, um das zu charakterisieren,
was er tatsächlich beschrieb
an den Füßen seines lieben verstorbenen Haller,
und nachdem er diesen Artikel geschrieben hatte,
fing er an, sich sehr, sehr besorgt zu fühlen,
tatsächlich so besorgt, dass er innerhalb eines
Jahres beschloss, den Artikel
zu einem kleinen Buch zu erweitern, in dem im Grunde
der Artikel wiederholt wird, aber er  beginnt
mit diesem kunstvollen Kotau zum
Brüllen, wenn der große Mann
nur ein wenig länger gelebt hätte, hätte er
es gesehen und er hätte verstanden, dass
sie diese Dinge genommen hat, und es ist nicht so, dass
ich besser bin als er oder dass er sich geirrt hat
dachte, aber dass ich
einfach die Art von Arbeit
tun könnte, die er getan hätte, wenn er nur länger da gewesen wäre, ist es
widerlich
kriecherisch okay, aber es lässt
erahnen, wie sehr Blumenbach sich fühlte
Voller Ehrfurcht vor der Anwesenheit von
Hollar auf dem Feld,
aber und vor allem sagt er im Grunde
, dass Holler alle nass sind, und er geht so
weit, dass er in der berühmten
Rezension, in der er
den Ruf des Casters Friedrich
herabsetzte und herausstellte, dass er die experimentellen Ergebnisse aushöhlt, sagte
das waren die gründe für diese veranlagung
von wolf waren falsch
wir liegen einfach falsch während er und
alle anderen in deutschland vorher einfach ja gesagt hatten
mr.  Haller, so muss es sein,
plötzlich sagt Blue Box, er ist ganz nass,
ohne aber einmal zu sagen, Wolf hatte
Recht, okay, Blue und Bath will nie
retten, Wolf hatte Recht, und ich werde
mehr daraus machen als andere Leute, es ist
sehr wichtig  Diese blaue Box sieht seine
Position von Anfang an in Rivalität
mit Wolfs Position,
also ist es nicht nur so, dass er
mit Halloran die
Vorformation ist, sondern auch, dass er etwas anbieten möchte, von
dem er glaubt, dass es sich
radikal von dem unterscheidet, was er hätte
getan mit einem Visa-Sinn Yanis und ich denke
, dass das wirklich wichtig ist, denn
was wir später sehen werden, ist, wie sich das
auf spätere sehr kontroverse
Aussagen auswirkt, dass er erst
1782 in der zweiten Ausgabe des
Handbuchs Lumba den
Begriff einführt  von Building Philippe finden Sie es weder
in der Originalausgabe von 1779
noch in Teil eins, der 1779 erscheint,
noch in Teil zwei, der von 1780 erscheint,
sondern nur in 1783  Es scheint,
aber was für mich wirklich interessant ist, ist,
dass er, was 1782 erscheint,
die Definitionssprache wörtlich auflistet
und sie ohne
Ausarbeitung und ohne theoretische
Begründung in den Text einfügt, aber er tut es später in dem
Buch, wenn er es einbringt  Ein fruchtbarer Weg
, den ich für wirklich wichtig halte, sind
die Experimente von Ihnen Kultivator
zur Übertragung der Transformation von
Tabakpflanzen von einer Art in eine
andere und dann zurück, die zeigen
, dass Artfixität kein wesentliches
Merkmal des Tier- oder physischen
Lebensreichs mehr ist  Das werden
entscheidende Daten sein.
Was für mich wirklich wichtig ist, ist, dass
es in diesem Buch von
oder in der Annahme dieser Sprache im Jahr
782 kein Anzeichen für methodologische oder
erkenntnistheoretische Bedenken im Bloom Box-
Teil gibt, sondern in der dritten Ausgabe von  Im
Handbuch von 1788 finden wir
interessanterweise ein plötzliches methodologisches
erkenntnistheoretisches Selbstbewusstsein, das er
als Ursache für dieses f schreibt  Der ormative Antrieb
kann zugegebenermaßen so wenig angeführt werden wie
der Anziehungskraft oder der Schwerkraft und anderen
allgemein anerkannten Naturkräften,
es reicht aus, dass es sich um eine unverwechselbare
Kraft handelt, deren unbestreitbare Existenz und
weitreichender Einfluss in der gesamten Natur
durch Erfahrung offenbart wird und deren
beständige Phänomene eine Wirkung bieten  viel
bereitwilligere und klarere Einblicke in die Generation
und viele andere der wichtigsten
Themen der Naturgeschichte als andere
Theorien, die in ihrer Erklärung angeboten werden.
Bitte verstehen Sie, dass es hier zwei Punkte
gibt. Der erste Punkt ist, dass dies eine
experimentelle, keine metaphysische Behauptung ist,
und der zweite, dass  Es ist eine vergleichsweise
erfolgreiche Behauptung, dass es
in Bezug auf seine Wirksamkeit bei der Lösung von
Problemen in
der lebensexperimentellen Biowissenschaft nicht nach einem absoluten Standard der
Perfektion oder Vollständigkeit zu beurteilen ist. Okay, was
ich vorschlagen möchte, ist, dass Sie sehen werden, wenn Sie
diese Bemerkungen zur Methodik studieren
der Abdruck genau der Sätze, die
ich von ironischen Modellen und tha zitiert habe  Es gibt
hier methodologisch eine klare Kontinuität
zwischen der Konzeption dessen, was
empirische Wissenschaft tun kann und was nicht, und
der Rolle der Ontologie-Metaphysik
von Romero bis Bloomberg, also geht
es nicht nur darum, seinen
Begriff scape zu ergreifen und ihn in Big einzustecken  O
Smith, es ist auch eine methodologische
Identifizierung dessen,
was für die Naturwissenschaft möglich und was nicht möglich ist.
Was mich interessiert, ist die Art und Weise, wie
diese methodologische Reflexion sich zu
beugen beginnt, wenn sich die Ausgaben seiner
Texte von diesem Zeitpunkt an, im Jahr
1789, entwickeln, den er
schreibt  Der Begriff Gestaltungstrieb dient ebenso wie die
Begriffe Anziehung und Schwerkraft etc.
nicht mehr und nicht weniger, als eine Kraft zu bezeichnen
, deren stete Wirkung
erkannt wird, deren Ursache aber ebensowenig
wie die Pausen der anderen
doch so allgemein anerkannten
Naturkräfte für uns Gleichheiten oculto bleiben
das hindert uns jedoch in keiner
Weise daran, zu versuchen
, den Aufwand und die Auswirkungen zu untersuchen
dieser Kraft durch empirische
Beobachtungen und um sie hier unter allgemeine Gesetze zu bringen,
Bloom Bach
beruft sich ausdrücklich auf Newton, bereits mit den Begriffen
Anziehungskraft, Schwerkraft kann man die
Newtonsche Präsenz bewahren, aber hier gibt es eine
ausdrückliche explizite methodologische Verbeugung
vor Newton, und es gab eine
Reihe wirklich guter  Essays, die die
virtuelle Allgegenwärtigkeit dieses Rückgriffs auf
Newton und Newtons
Verzicht auf eine kausale Erklärung der Gravitation demonstrieren, und
die Behauptung, dass er keine kausale Erklärung liefern muss, wenn er
die empirische Realität der Gravitation in sehr guter Allgemeinheit begründen und definieren kann
Dies
ist genau die Art von Argument,
die die wichtigsten empirischen Forschungen
im 18. Jahrhundert in all diesen
Bereichen über feinstoffliche Materie und über
diese entstehenden Kräfte anführen. Was ich
hier also vorschlagen möchte, ist, dass Team sehr viel
Teil eines Wesens über die Entwicklung
in ist  der Fortschritt der
Naturwissenschaften zu einer bestimmten Art von
Auton  weg von Metaphysik und Ontologie
einerseits und hin zu einer bestimmten
Art von internalistisch-relativistischen
Erfolgs- oder Wirksamkeitsstandards, und ich denke, es ist
wirklich wichtig, dass Bloomberg
ständig über den allgemein anerkannten Charakter dieser Kräfte argumentiert, von dem
niemand sagt, dass er es mir sagen
wird  So etwas wie Schwerkraft gibt es nicht, also was
ist das für ein Schwachsinn, den Sie mir bringen wollen,
dass wir nicht über die Lebenskräfte sprechen können,
es gibt keine grundlegende erkenntnistheoretische
Lücke zwischen den empirischen
Beobachtungen und den
empirischen Beobachtungen des anderen und
das ist wirklich so  entscheidend, und
ich denke, das ist etwas, was mich sehr beunruhigt,
was den Conte anbelangt, aber wir werden später
mehr darüber von Kollegen hören.
Ich denke, es ist wichtig zu fragen, ob
wir in Bloomberg irgendwelche Zweideutigkeiten über
die Angemessenheit seiner Theorie in Bezug auf ihre
Empirie sehen  Charakter sogar bis Ende
der 1780er Jahre und ich denke, die Antwort ist
eindeutig nein, also was ist es,
das ihn nervös macht?  nk zwei
Dinge passieren und ich denke, dass es
sehr wichtig ist, sie zu unterscheiden.
Ich denke, er wird sehr
aggressiv von kosmofreiem jüdischem
Essen herausgefordert, was ihn einlädt, das ist irgendwie
hinterhältig, beide laden ihn zur Akademie
in St.  Petersburg, um die
Frage der Ernährung als Lebenskraft zu untersuchen,
und er lädt mich über ein paar
andere Leute ein, er gibt den Preis an Blum
zurück an jemand anderen, und
dann veröffentlicht er diese beiden
preisgekrönten Arbeiten mit einem Nachtrag zu einer
Arbeit  sich selbst doppelt so lange wie
einer der Artikel, der im Grunde argumentiert, dass
keiner so gut ist wie seine eigene Theorie,
möchte ich Ihnen vorschlagen, dass
Blum ba am 78
ihn erschrecken, was ihn daran beunruhigt
und wie sich das widerspiegelt, meine
antwort ist, dass ihn
daran interessanterweise nicht die Methode stört,
ihre Metaphysik, wovor er Angst
hat, ist das, was er seinen Materialismus sieht,
was er als eine Kontinuität zwischen der
physikalischen Chemie sieht  Kräften auf der einen Seite
und den Lebenskräften auf der anderen Seite ist dies
für ihn sehr beängstigend für eine Reihe von
ich würde eher metaphysischen als
methodischen Gründen argumentieren  Söhne und
genau das ist es, was Kant
an Boomba liebt und das in
Boomba aufgreift,
und das gibt Loom Bach ein noch sichereres Gefühl
, so dass, wenn wir uns die zweite
Ausgabe des Essays für mittlere Geschwindigkeit ansehen,
Bloom Box dies zu einem Vokal macht, es ist a
wirklich leidenschaftlich darüber, in dem er sagt,
niemand glaubt fester als
ich an den Unterschied zwischen organischer
Materie und rein physischer Materie, also
springt er auf den Zug des Anti-High/Low-
Zuismus auf, der ein Kernkonzept von
cont Berndt ist  zurück und
bestand im Grunde darauf, dass seine ganze Theorie des
Schlafaufbaus sich auf die Natur organischer
Materie bezieht, es hat nichts mit dem
Übergang von physischer Materie zu
organischer Materie zu tun, es gibt keine Kontinuität in der
Natur, es gibt eine radikale Diskontinuität,
und aber ich möchte dies vorschlagen  Das ist
genau das, was Gott von
Bloom Ba will und was Cut von Luba nimmt,
und was ich Ihnen weiter sagen möchte,
ist, dass genau die Elemente,
als die sich Romero identifiziert, reimen  Kern
, den Begriff der bevorstehenden
propulsiven Nasaw als Kernbegriff im Bloom
Box Building Sleep zu halten, während er als
empirische Beobachtungsstrategie funktioniert und
sogar als empirisches Ergebnis eine ganze
Reihe metaphysischer und
epistemologischer Probleme um sich herum aufgebaut hat
, die Bloom Box nie anspricht, aber sie
kann
nicht davon ausgehen, argumentiere ich ein wenig zu
leichtfertig, dass die Trennung zwischen der
physikalischen Natur der Kräfte und dem
unverwechselbaren Charakter von Teba, die
ontologisch in einer separaten
Ordnung organischer Materie begründet ist, zur Grundlage wird, auf der
Cantar angibt, dass
es niemals ein Newton geben kann  des
Grashalms und wobei er argumentiert, dass die
Biowissenschaften ein Projekt sind, das
niemals erfolgreich durchgeführt werden kann, beide
Argumente wurden meines Erachtens sofort
von all seinen Nachfolgern sowohl
in der Philosophie als auch in den
Biowissenschaften abgelehnt
in den nach mir kommenden Arbeiten bestätigt oder verworfen wird,
aber es ist sicherlich mein
Argument, dass die Vergangenheit Kant
Ich habe nicht den Weg vorgeschlagen, der
zum Erfolg der Lebenswissenschaften in
Deutschland oder in der westlichen Welt im
Allgemeinen geführt hat.
Vielen Dank